our main story tonight concerns facial
recognition the thing that makes sure my
iPhone won't open unless it sees my face
or the face of any toucan but that is it
facial recognition technologies be
showcased in TV shows and movies for
years Denzel Washington even discovered
a creative use for it in the 2006 action
movie deja vu
we have facial recognition software yeah
let's use it on the bag Cross Master -
all the bags on the south side of the
city in the 48 hours leading up to the
explosion right don't think that's ever
been used this way same day bingo bingo
indeed Denzel with smart believable plot
development like that is frankly no
wonder that deja vu receives such
glowing IMDB reviews as an insult to
anybody who finished elementary school
worst movie of all time
more like deja ARPU and my personal
favorites a one-star review that reads
bruce greenwood as always is great and
so sexy and there's a cat who survives a
review that was clearly written either
by bruce greenwood or that cat now the
technology behind facial recognition has
been around for years but recently as
it's grown more sophisticated is
applications have expanded greatly
freezers it's no longer just humans who
can be the targets the i farm sensor
scans each fish and uses automatic image
processing to uniquely identify each
individual a number of symptoms are
recognized including loser fish yes
loser fish which by the way is an actual
industry term now that company says it
can detect which fish are losers by
facial scan which is important because
can you tell which one of these fish is
a loser and which one is a winner are
you sure about that because they're the
same fish this is why you need a
computer but the growth of facial
recognition and what it's capable of
brings with a host of privacy and civil
liberties issues because if you want a
sense of just how terrifying this
technology could be if it becomes part
of everyday life just watch as a Russian
TV presenter demonstrates an app called
find face yes the rule if you find
yourself in a cafe with an attractive
girl and you don't have the guts to
approach her no problem
all you need is a smartphone and the
application fine face find new friends
take a picture and wait for the result
now you're already looking at her
profile page burn it all down burn
everything down I'll realize that this
is a sentence that no one involved in
creating the app ever once thought but
just imagine that from a woman's
perspective you're going about your day
when suddenly you get a random message
from a guy you don't know that says
hello
I saw you in cafe earlier and used find
face app to learn your name and contact
information I'll pick you up from your
place at 8:00 don't worry I already know
where you live but one of the biggest
users of facial recognition is perhaps
unsurprisingly law enforcement since
2011 the FBI has logged more than three
hundred and ninety thousand facial
recognition searches and the databases
law enforcement pulling from include
over one hundred and seventeen million
American adults and incorporates among
other things driver's license photos
from residents of all these states so
roughly one in two of us have had our
photo search this way and the police
will argue that this is all for the best
in fact here is an official with the
London police explaining why they use it
they're here in London we've had the
London Bridge attacked the Westminster
Bridge attacked the suspects involved in
that the people were guilty of those
offences were often known by the
authorities had they been on some
database had they been picked up by
cameras beforehand we may have been able
to prevent those atrocities and that
would definitely be a price worth paying
okay it's hard to come out against the
prevention of atrocities this show is
and always has been anti atrocity but
the key question there is what's the
trade-off if the police can't guarantee
that they could prevent all robberies
but the only way to do that is by having
an officer stationed in every bathroom
watching you every time you take a
I'm not sure everyone would agree that
it's worth it and the people who do
might want that for reasons other than
preventing crime and now it's actually a
very good time to be looking at this
issue because there are currently
serious concerns the facial-recognition
is being used to identify black lives
matter protesters and if that's true it
wouldn't actually be the first time as
this senior scientist
Google Timothy brew will tell you there
was an example with Baltimore Police and
the Freddie gray marches where they use
face recognition to identify protesters
and then they try to link them up with
their social media profiles and then
target them for arrests so right now a
lot of people are actually urging people
not to put images of protesters on
social media because there are people
out there who do whose job is just to
look up these people and and target them
it's true
join the Freddie gray protests police
officers used facial recognition
technology to look for people with
outstanding warrants and arrest them
which is a pretty sinister way to
undermine the right to assemble so
tonight let's take a look at facial
recognition let's start with the fact
that even as big companies like
Microsoft Amazon and IBM have been
developing it and governments all over
the world have been happily rolling it
out there haven't been many rules or a
framework in place for how it is used in
Britain they've actually been
experimenting with facial recognition
zones even putting up signs alerting you
to the fact that you're about to enter
one which seems polite but what what
happens when one man decided he didn't
actually want his face scanned this man
didn't want to be caught by the police
cameras so he covered his face but he
stopped him they photographed him anyway
an argument followed what's your
suspicion the the fact that he walked
past I would do the same it's a cold day
as well we've found that the police
offices I'll sweep the pump in so I've
got me back up I'll sit with me cough
I've got on there 90 pound fine there
you go look at that no effects next 90
pound well done yeah that guy Ritchie
character was rightly mad about that and
incidentally if you are not British and
you're looking at that man then at me
I'm wondering how we both came from the
same Island let me quickly explain
British people come in to variations so
emotionally-stunted that they're
practically comatose and cheerfully
telling large groups of policemen to
off and do one if you're gonna take
a photo with me face there's absolutely
nothing in between the two and the UK's
by no means alone in building out a
system
Australia is investing heavily in a
national facial biometric system called
the capability which sounds like the
name of a Netflix original movie
although that's actually perfect if you
want people to notice it think that
seems interesting and then forget it
ever existed and you don't have to
imagine what this technology would look
like in the hands of an authoritarian
government because China is
unsurprisingly embracing it in a big way
for more countries in la soie we can
match every face with an ID card and
trace all your movements back one week
in time we can match your face with your
car match you with your relatives and
the people you're in touch with with
enough cameras we can know who you
frequently meet that is a terrifying
level of surveillance imagine the Eye of
Sauron but instead of scouring Middler
for the One Ring he was just really into
knowing where all his orcs like to go to
dinner and some state-funded developers
in China seem weirdly oblivious to just
how sinister their projects sound China
what is that the Terminator is a a
favorite film of war founder so play for
you the same name but they want to prove
something good in the list system so ok
in the Terminator Skynet is evil reigns
down death from the sky but in China
Skynet is good yeah not a difference oh
that's the difference is it you know
it's not exactly reassuring that you
called your massive all-encompassing AI
network Skynet
but a good version because it'd be like
if the Today Show built a robot
journalist and called it Matt Lauer but
good oh yeah this one's completely
different sure he does also have a
button under his office desk but all it
does is release lilac air freshener this
is the good version the point is this
technology raises troubling
philosophical questions about personal
freedom and right now there are also
some very immediate practical issues
because even though it is currently
being used this technology is still very
much a work in progress and its error
rate is particularly high when it comes
to matching faces in real time in fact
in the UK when human rights researchers
watched police put one such system to
the test they found that only 8 out of
42 matches were verifiably correct and
that's even before we get into the fact
that these systems can have some
worrying blah
spots as one MIT researcher found out
when testing out numerous algorithms
including Amazon's own recognition
system at first glance MIT researchers
joy bull and weenie says the overall
accuracy rate was high even though all
companies better detected and identified
men's faces than women's but the error
rate grew as she dug deeper lighter male
faces were the easiest to guess the
gender on and darker female faces were
the hardest one system couldn't even
detect if she had a face and the others
misidentified her gender white guy no
problem yeah white guy no problem which
yes is the unofficial motto of history
but it's not like what we needed right
now was for computers to somehow find a
way to exacerbate the problem and it
gets worse
in one test Amazon system even failed on
the face of Oprah Winfrey someone so
recognizable her magazine only had to
type the first letter of her name and
your brain auto-completed the rest and
that's not all a federal study of more
than a hundred facial recognition
algorithms found that Asian and African
American people were up to a hundred
times more likely to be misidentified
than white man so that is clearly
concerning and on top of all of this
some law-enforcement agencies have been
using these systems in ways they weren't
exactly designed to be used in 2017
police were looking for this beer thief
the surveillance image wasn't clear
enough for facial recognition software
to identify him so instead police used a
picture of a look-alike which happened
to be actor Woody Harrelson that
produced names of several possible
suspects and led to an arrest yeah they
used a photo of Woody Harrelson to catch
a beer thief and how dare you drag Woody
Harrelson into this this is the man that
one's got drunk at Wimbledon in this
magnificent hat made this facial
expression in the stands and in doing so
accidentally made tennis interesting for
a day he doesn't deserve prison for that
he deserves the Wimbledon trophy and
there's been multiple instances where
investigators have had such confidence
in a match they've made disastrous
mistakes a few years back Sri Lankan
authorities mistakenly targeted this
Brown University student as a suspect in
a heinous crime which made for pretty
awful finals week on the morning of
april 25th in the midst of final season
I woke up in my dorm room 2:35 missed
calls all frantically informing me that
I had been falsely identified as one of
the terrorists involved in the recent
Easter attacks in my beloved motherland
Sri Lanka that's terrible
finals week is already bad enough what
with staying up all night alternating
shots of 5-hour energy and java monster
mean beam while trying to push your
brain to remember the differences
between baroque and Rococo architecture
without waking up to find out the Evo's
I've been accused of terrorism because a
computer sucks up faces now on the one
hand these technical issues could get
smoothed out over time but even if this
technology eventually becomes perfect we
should really be asking ourselves how
much we're comfortable with it being
used by police by governments by
companies or indeed by anyone and we
should be asking that right now because
we're about to cross a major line for
years many tech companies approached
facial recognition with caution in fact
in 2011 the then chairman of Google said
it was the one technology the company
had held back because it could be used
in a very bad way and think about that
it was - Pandora's Box e for Silicon
Valley the world's most enthusiastic
Pandora's Box openers and even some of
the big companies that have developed
facial recognition algorithms have
designed it for use unlimited data sets
like mug shots or driver's license
photos but now something important has
changed and it is because of this guy
wonton tat and his company Clearview AI
and I'll let him describe what it does
quite simply Clearview is basically a
search engine for faces so anyone in law
enforcement can upload a face to the
system and it finds any other publicly
available material that matches that
particular face ok so the key phrase
there is publicly available material
because Clearview says it's collected a
database of 3 billion images that is
larger than any other facial recognition
database in the world and it's done that
by scraping them from public facing
social media like Facebook LinkedIn
Twitter and Instagram so for instance
cliff Hughes system would theoretically
include this publicly available photo of
tante at at what appears to be Burning
Man or this one of him wearing a suit
from the exclusive Santa Clau
after dark collection at Men's Wearhouse
and this very real photo of him
shirtless and lighting a cigarette with
blood covered hands which by the way is
his profile photo untitled because yes
of course he's also a musician I can
only assume that that's the cover of an
album called
automatic skip if this ever comes up on
a Pandora station and Tom tats
willingness to do what others have not
been willing to do and that is scraped
the whole internet for photos has made
this company a genuine game changer in
the worst possible way just what does
the impresses our journalists by running
a sample search so here's the photo you
uploaded to me mm-hmm a headshot from
CNN mm-hmm so first few images it's
found it's found a few different
versions of that that same picture but
now as we scroll down we're starting to
see pictures of me that are not from
that original image
oh go to it Wow oh my god so this this
photograph is from my local newspaper
where I lived in Ireland and this photo
would have been taken when I'm when I
was like 16 Wow that's crazy
yeah it is well though here is some
advice if there is an embarrassing photo
of you from when you're a teenager don't
run away from it make it the center of
your television shows promotional
campaign and own it use the fact that
your teenage years were a hormonal
stalingrad harness the pain but the
notion that someone can take your
picture and immediately find out
everything about you is alarming enough
even before you discover that over 600
law enforcement agencies have been using
Clearview service and you're probably in
that database even if you don't know it
if a photo of you has been uploaded to
the Internet there is a decent chance
that Clear View has it even if someone
uploaded it without your consent even if
you untagged yourself or later set your
account of private and if you're
thinking hold on isn't this against the
Terms of Service for internet companies
you should know Clearview actually
received cease and desist orders from
Twitter YouTube and Facebook earlier
this year but it has refused to stop
arguing that it has a First Amendment
right to harvest data from social media
which is just not at all how the First
Amendment works you might as well argue
that you have an Eighth Amendment right
to dress up rabbits like John Lennon
that amendment
does not cover what I think you think it
does and yet TomTom insists that this
was all inevitable so we should all
frankly be glad that he's the one who
did it
I think the choice now is not between
like no facial recognition and facial
recognition is between you know bad
facial recognition and responsible
facial recognition and we want to be in
the responsible category well sure you
want to be but are you because there are
a lot of red flags here for starters
apps he developed before this included
one called Trump hair which would just
add Trump's hair to a user's photo and
another called vidi ho that fished its
own users tricking them into sharing
access to their Gmail account and then
spanning all their contacts so I'm not
sure that I would want to trust my
privacy to this guy if however I was
looking for someone to build an app that
let me put Ron Swanson's mustache on my
face as my checking account was quietly
drained sure then he'd be the top of my
list and despite clear his repeated
reassurances that its product is
intended only for law enforcement as if
that is inherently a good thing he's
already put it in a lot of other
people's hands because in addition to
users like the DEA and the FBI he's also
made it available to employees at Kohl's
Walmart and Macy's which has alone
completed more than 6,000 facial
searches and it gets worse
because they've also reportedly tried to
pitch their service to congressional
candidate and white supremacist Paul
Nealon suggesting that they could help
him use unconventional databases for
extreme opposition research which is a
terrifying series of words to share a
sentence with white supremacists now
cliff who says that that offer was
unauthorized but when questioned about
who else he might be willing to work
with Tom tats answer hasn't been
reassuring there's some countries that
would never sell to that at very adverse
to the US for example like China and
Russia Iran North Korea so those are the
things that are definitely off the table
and about countries that think that
being gay should be illegal it's a crime
so like I said you know we want to make
sure that we do everything correctly
mainly focus on the u.s. in Canada and
the interest has been overwhelming to be
honest just so much interest that you
know you're taking in one day at a time
yeah that's no
terribly comforting when you ask a
farmer if you'd let foxes into the
henhouse the answer you hope for is know
not the interest from foxes has been
overwhelming to be honest just so much
interest so you know we're taking it one
day at a time and unsurprisingly
reporters for BuzzFeed have found that
Clear View has quietly offered its
services to entities in Saudi Arabia and
the United Arab Emirates countries that
view human rights laws with the same
level of respect that clear view seems
to have to Facebook's Terms of Service
so facial recognition technology is
already here the question is what can we
do about it well some are trying to find
ways to thwart the cameras themselves hi
guys it's me Jillian again with a new
makeup tutorial today's topic is how to
hide from cameras okay
first that's probably not a scalable
solution and second I'm not sure if that
makes you less identifiable or the most
identifiable person on earth officers
are on the lookout for a young woman
dark hair medium build looks like a mine
who went through a shredder look clearly
what we really need to do is put limits
on how this technology can be used and
some locations have laws in place
already
San Francisco banned facial recognition
last year but the scope of that is
limited to City law enforcement it
doesn't affect state and federal use or
private companies meanwhile Illinois has
a law requiring companies to obtain
written permission before collecting a
person's fingerprints facial scans or
other identifying biological
characteristics and that is good but we
also need a comprehensive nationwide
policy and we need it right now because
again there are worries that it is being
used in the protests that we are seeing
now and the good news is that just this
week thanks to those protests and two
years of work by activists some
companies did pull back from facial
recognition for instance IBM says
they'll no longer develop facial
recognition meanwhile Amazon said it was
putting a one-year hold on working with
law enforcement and Microsoft said it
wouldn't sell its technology to police
without federal regulation but there is
nothing to stop those companies from
changing their mind if people's outrage
dies down and for the record while
Clearview says it's canceling its
private contracts it's also said it will
keep working with the police just as it
will keep harvesting you
photos from the internet so if Clearview
is gonna keep grabbing our photos at the
very least there may be a way to let
them know what you think about that so
if the next time you feel the need to
upload a photo maybe throw in an extra
one for them to collect maybe hold up a
sign that says these photos were taken
unwillingly and I'd rather you not be
looking at them or if that feels too
complicated just Clearview that
really does get the message across and
remember these photos are often being
searched by law enforcement so you may
want to take this opportunity to talk to
the investigators looking through your
photos maybe something like I don't look
like Woody Harrelson but while I have
your attention
defund the police really whatever you
feel is most important to tell them you
should put on a sign that's our show
thank you so much for watching we'll see
you next week good night
[Music]
you